tip softly into the Carolina and Shay comes
over to rescue and it's back to Center for Ben
sherat picked up here's Patty Kane Patrick
Kane rips one go Che out the glove save and
he didn't know where the puck was sing feed
goov another save it's behind him valeno got
the second opportunity still lose Scramble
for it Petri lets it Fly that's blocked
here's sherro he's in deep Cent In Front the
bricket shot is blocked as well by burs and
Carolina will counter Tavo teravan trying
to get it through for nious and that play
is cut off katam will force it in deeper
and Uso will swing it around kept in by
valeno spins Carolina still keeps in Easy stick
Sav by Uso away from sherat here's D'Angelo in
deep Sanders coming through return one Tim from
terraine doing it forever and well off for Shay
he lost cop picks it up and back the other way
Michael rasm gets the shot away quick save and
there he is Wings able to kill it off we're back
to five aside Mason on it for Carolina swinging
around blind pass for NES by birs lets it Fly hit
a skate in front and block never made it on goal
n got another chance looking for the tip and they
score off the redirect what a pass that was really
really good shift by The KES in the offensive zone
and starts with bent Burns in a shooting mentality
which he's had his entire career put pucks toward
the net two efforts here's the third effort and
this one is the diagonal pass of the back post
outstanding in Vision here look at n the native
Tex in one year this past year in value you saying
they've got the cash they should pay the man uh
yeah he's helped transform this franchise back
to its Glory tonight is his 399th game behind the
Hurricane's bench off the post really really good
shot yes a Go's best friend indeed and you'll see
here come the wings on the attack and Petri who
could sling it he saw a hint to Daylight watch it
from his vantage point he sees a little hint
to Daylight top glove they're down JT comper
as well so down top two centers got it across
oh rips one coming across the body in a stick
save for huso he'll dump it down deep for Daniel
sprong gives it back for Patrick Kane talking to
brind more about case he's still got the silk
Ms amazing shot for checkov makes the save
there little Rugby scrum in the corner sing
to work his man over gos to spare the chance
Kane on it now that shot deflected looked like
a hit off a slaven yeah y caught the glass big
shift here for the wings side of the net most
of them is a San Jose Shark but he's in very
nicely Carolina good left pad save by H alert
left pad save at that kept in by peshi nicely
Carolina try to force the issue speaking of n
he is could have been forcing the issue yeah
I'm not sure nation's going to be so pleased with
that audio clip centered in front oh what a stop
Point Blank Billy huso by huso outstanding re he
sets up on that short side Glu side post watch
him hugging the post on his feet post the post on
his feet which I like allows him to get a better
jump on this net run opportunity and watch him
push forward seal all the holes momentarily and
volo's back at Center some good adjustments
by the wings here I like the shorter passes
oh valeno turns it over the shot a big save
Camy was all alone and Billy huso came up big
again cop on the face off Detroit able to win
it there's Walman through the traffic oh big
save there go check up kicking out the left pad
that was a high danger chance on that deflected
opportunity kov watching scanning a lot of uh a
lot of points in the dressing room fighting him
for sure and Joseph's got some uh some points as
well for taking on the fight no doubt that shot
score what a rip R mustion from the side beats
coov and we're tied at one from the shooting
standpoint and for Fier to catch the check off
he's got a square up on this Puck he doesn't
get all the way Square start with the shooter
mentality he sees that daylight short side they
tried him there earlier even though his glov been
cooking but Ras MST says I'll shoot there couldn't
do much with it there wman for the wings kept in
The Far Side by D'Angelo here's AO to the front of
the net for the redirect from n and a great stop
there from phly huso to bring it his own end gets
it off for hole main will tip in the checkov has
the lane turns it right over oh stop Patrick Kane
an awful turnover by COA he's looking up at the
scoreboard here at Little Caesar re he can here's
coov he's got time he's got space and that was a
Little Caesar's Pizza extra pepperoni he cooked
it and served it right up the middle but I'm going
to give him props for Carolina pesi will go back
in Chase table on your point that's exactly part
of the reason why we want to see best on best oh
youo misplayed that and it's in Jordan Stall two
misplays one at each end Coach checkov able to
bail himself out and youo could not do the same
Carolina and this is exactly where your for check
comes in because Uso goes out to stop it with the
paddle he's unable to and as a result that kum's
off the board so now he's off balance and he tries
to catch it with the heal he also tries to poke
check it but you have to be alert and aware of
who you're playing against and the Captain Jordan
Stall mcain with they sparkling new Red Wings
oh gorgeous where Gordy how still has a stall
by the way right that shot is stopped Seth Jarvis
breaking in all loone and above every Locker yeah
lineage greatness and lineage in their history and
here come the canes on the attack it's Seth Jarvis
who pulls it from backhand to forehand not one but
two chances and I just mentioned goalie having to
forget when they make a mistake can just play the
next shot and Uso does an outstanding similar as
ran O'Reilly that's how you would a few Stanley
Cups both of them right yep Nate just takes a look
oh whips a pass across nice look what a move shot
stop by the canes and they're advancing the puck
through zones from the neutral into the offense
look at coach get the Yami taking that puck for
a walk he's got it on a strike like a yo-yo
unreal in behind him through Hall back around
Hall and good point blank save by H look at the
positioning by H sometimes the skilled team and
skilled players are guilty of that looking for
that perfect play ma whips it around the boards
get in by a centered in front shot oh great close
save again since he's not opting to pass good
read there byus that shot is stop rebound loose
CMI from his knees try to push it home I don't
believe the see penalty is coming yes it is jarck
put it out of place delay game minutes delay game
through center with some speed finds meeno back
behind the net big factor no Jordan Stall on this
penalty kill unit all the way across oh his shot
is STO not to break it really key stop there by
huso and down to the other end Wing snapping the
puck around Big Time save here by Peter Z got it
across finds Petri in deep now everybody's got
to be in deep for Detroit yeah we'll keep an
eye on huso as well 4 seconds left in the power
play set it in front all alone a save go check
out hesi will take a look over his shoulder
stronga back behind the net centered in front
oh fabry the great opportunity and coov denied
and the horn sounds what a performance by P coov